OK, last question today.
Hey, David, are you worried about violence?
If Donald Trump loses in November?
I want to be really careful when talking about
this because I worry that I'm stepping into
a minefield where I might be giving people
ideas and I really don't want to do that,
which is why I've sort of resisted talking
about this.
But I think at this point it deserves some
discussion.
OK, let's game it out.
Joe Biden wins by a lot.
What do Trump ists do?
Joe Biden wins by a tiny bit.
What do trumpets do?
I actually think the more dangerous scenario
is if Biden wins by a little bit, because
if Biden really just crushes Donald Trump,
my instinct is that you will see Trump ists
sort of just like pretend nothing ever happened
and say, hey, you know, coronavirus was a
unique circumstance.
This isn't really a big loss for Trump.
This was, you know, people voting because
of a pandemic that affected every country.
This doesn't say anything about Trump.
OK.
Biden's the president.
Good luck with that, guys.
And I think you would see Trump has to be
relatively quiet.
If Biden absolutely blows out Donald Trump
now, more likely is that it's going to be
a maybe a closer election no matter who wins.
The scenario that scares me is if Biden wins
very narrowly, very, very narrowly.
And Trump fuels the idea that something unfair
happened.
That's something that the election cannot
be trusted, that the results have been doctored,
that it was rigged in some way.
That's the scenario that really scares me,
particularly in the period between Election
Day and what would be Joe Biden's inauguration
day.
That period, in
my mind, could become one of these where you
want to stay
home when the virus is spreading.
Maybe you would want to stay home during that
as well in certain parts of the country.
I believe that law enforcement locally, state
federally is more than equipped to handle
it.
But that doesn't mean that there could not
be dangers.
And yes, it is something I'm thinking of and
I am hopeful that it does not go that way.
If Trump wins, I think it's less likely that
you see that violence.
I think the scenario most likely to lead to
violence would be a narrow Biden victory,
which Trump cast doubt on the integrity of
the election in a way that really gets his
base going and going crazy.
I hope I'm wrong.
Let me know your thoughts about what you expect,
what you think there.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
It is Friday morning.
Producer Pat Ford is taking the reins of the
bonus show.
So that's it for me for the week.
I will be back with
you on Monday.